let's go to
monte carlo integration i promise you
something
if you learn what monte carlo
integration is
you will never ever in your life
will have to evaluate any more integrals
never i promise to you i give you my
word
and this is a simple method to
approximate
integrals
and basically what we are looking for is
we would like to integrate the function
and we can take
samples of this function what does it
mean we will check it
out in a second so we will take some
samples of this function and we would
like to reconstruct the integral of it
if we do this this is what's called
monte carlo integration and this was
founded
during the second world war bar by
stanislav
and his co-workers during the manhattan
project so this was the atomic bomb
project
they had unbelievably difficult
integrals to solve
and they had to came up with a numerical
solution in order to at least
approximate
so this is what they came up with
there's two different kinds
of monte carlo integration the keys
i have this function f of x and i would
like to integrate this from a to b
so this is a definite integral what i
can do
is hit or miss monte carlo or sample
mean
monte carlo 99.9 of the case we use the
sample mean
but just for the intuition and to to
visualize what is going on i will show
you the intermission as well
and at all times we can choose how to
take
samples from this function so let's take
a look at this
this is the recipe like for wonderful
vinash midsole this is the recipe for
monte carlo integration
you draw this function that you have on
a paper
you close it in a box that you know the
size of
and let the size of the box be a you
throw
lots of random points on this paper
and for every single point you have you
determine if it is above or below this
function
and then you have a magical formula
you use this formula and you will get
the integral
the more the more points you have on the
paper the better
so i compute the ratio of hits
the points below the curve the function
compared to all the samples that i have
how does it look like this looks
more or less like this so this
immediately gives you the intuition that
the reds are above the function the
blues are below the function
so i would like to know the ratio of
blues to
all samples because this gives you
exactly what intervals mean integrals
mean
the area below this curve
so get this
if i would be on a summer holiday i
could
have some beers and get a crazy idea
that i would go on top of my house
and imagine that i have a pool
of water and i will start throwing beach
balls in this pool
and after doing this for long enough i
could approximate the value of
pi it sounds like black magic
right provided that the walls are small
enough
and i am patient enough that this can
happen okay what is the recipe
let's go through it let's draw a unit
square somewhere
so the area of this square is going to
be one
let's draw a quarter of a unit circle
inside this box
and this is also of unit radius
now we start throwing these points we
compute the ratio
what is inside and how much is outside
we multiply the result by 4
and then we get pi so let me say this
again we multiply the results by
4 and we get pi
now how is this i mean it doesn't
doesn't sound like that it makes any
sense
but this is black magic and this works
let's take a closer look at why this
works
so i would like to compute the integral
the integral
would be below this function this is the
one
quarter of a sphere of a circle sorry
and
what is the area of the sphere r square
of
times pi well r is one so it's pi over
four
so what we are essentially approximating
here is
pi over four so i have
this when i solve this integral what i
get as a result is pi over four
but what do i need to do with this in
order to get pi multiplied by
or louder four yes
exactly so shadow cooper will be
proud for all of us physicists do a lot
of this
excellent yes what if you have a surface
this also works for multi-dimensional
functions
and you will actually compute
such a thing in the next assignment and
it's it's going to be absolutely trivial
so this
trivially generalizes for arbitrary
dimensions
well it better it better do because the
rendering equation is infinite
dimensional so
it has to take care of high dimensional
functions somehow